bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 78
sport numéro 30 c'est parti pour un
nouveau tour de l'actualité sportive du
département il est désormais l'homme le
plus rapide d'Europe sur le kilomètre
Yann dujarriier a été sacré champion
d'Europe de la distance sur piste il y a
quelques semaines porté à portrait à
suivre dans ce 7 8 sport lui est depuis
4 ans la voie du parisversailles 37 ans
Laurent Lepeltier est un jeune speaker
aux multiples casquettes rencontre avec
un passionné de sport qui rêve du Parc
des Princes et dans ce 78 sport nous
nous arrêterons avec nos invités sur la
zumba rose ce gigantesque cours de Zumba
permettra le 5 octobre prochain de
récolter des fonds pour la lutte contre
le cancer du sein et évidemment en fin
d'émission tous les résultats du weekend
mais tout d'abord place au rugby au
début de saison du plaisir Rugby Club
plutôt difficile dans la
manière
je le disais donc place au rugby deux
matchs de victoires une défaite sur ces
tris trois premières journées de
championnat de fédéral 3 ce weekend vous
gagnez à domicile 221 he face à Mo mais
je vous ai vu un peu pester sur le banc
Philippe oui on est actuellement à la
recherche d'un match référence on est en
début de saison on a récupéré à peu près
tous nos joueurs et bon il serait temps
de produire le jeu bah qu'on désire
produire pour pouvoir atteindre nos
objectifs qui sont comme on en avait
parlé l'an dernier finir dans les dans
les deux premiers de de la poule quoi
pour espérer voir les les prof
évidemment en fin de saison voilà vous
n'êtes pas encore satisfait du jeu
produit même s'il y a eu des renforts à
l'intersaison alors on a eu des renforts
mais comme à chaque fois qu'il y a des
renforts il faut le temps qu' qu'il
s'adapte au nouveau projets de jeu on a
eu aussi des départs de joueurs
importants et puis on a un certain
nombre de joueurs de l'équipe première
qui ont repris progressivement et qui
n'ont été disponies que cette semaine
donc tout ça fait que le groupe n'est
pas encore très homogène et qu'on se
cherche un peu et les résultats sont
recent qu'est-ce qui provoque toutes ces
fautes de main on a vu pas mal de fautes
de mains des en avant sur ce match face
à Mo
hier beaucoup d'En Avant beaucoup de de
jeux arrêtés rapidement donc pas
possibilité d'enchaîner TR qu temps de
jeu comme on aime le faire et comme on
on réussit pas mal d'habitude alors le
terrain glissant il avait plus quand
même des trompes d'eau le matin même si
l'après-midi c'était devenu un petit peu
sec et puis peut-être un manque un
manque d'attention un manque de
concentration des joueurs qui fait que
contre une équipe qu'on connaissait très
peu et qui qui n'a pas elle non plus
beaucoup brillé on s'est peut-être vu un
peu beau tout de suite et on n pas
réussi à mettre en place ce jeu précis
et l'échet bah qui devrait nous
permettre de de faire les résultatscés
ce jeu précis justement etch dont vous
parlez he votre capitaine François
Levillain l'apprécie tout
particulièrement CEN est une des plus
belles illustration je l'ai rencontré à
la sortie du match dimanche je vous
propose de d'écouter ces ces propos
l'envie de trop bien faire et surtout
aussi la conservation qui est pas
assurée au contact à chaque fois on ve
on veut on veut donner les ballons alors
que voilà on devrait multiplier les
temps de jeu et essayer de justement de
développer le jeu comme ça en
multipliant les temps de jeu quoi la
victoire est là les quatre points sont
là après voilà quoi si cette année on
veut enfin réussir à faire quelque chose
en face finale et se qualifier encore
mieux que les trois précédentes années
bah voilà tous ces matchs là il va
falloir les les gagner peu importe la
manière mais voilà il va falloir gagner
et prendre un maximum de points ça c'est
sûr prendre un maximum de points on le
disait pour les play-offs pourtant avec
ce jeu on va dire un petit peu encore à
tâon vous êtes plutôt bien bien classé
hein dans dans cette poule de fédéral 3
on va d'ailleurs jeter un coup d'œil au
classement vous avez donc deux victoires
je disais une défaite face à Vincen il y
a une semaine voilà vous êtes deuxième
execo c'est la différence de points que
que ça se joue Orléan est premier leader
qu'est-ce qu'il va vouloir faire pour
améliorer justement ce niveau de jeu
dans les prochaines semaines va falloir
s'entraîner mieux va falloir qu'il y ait
plus de que tout le monde adhère
vraiment à ce nouveau projet de jeu et
puis va falloir être concentré 80
minutes pendant au cours des matchs quoi
c'est toujours pareil hein même si on
s'entraîne bien un match ça dure 80
minutes il faut être à 100 120 % pendant
80 minutes et ça il y a des joueurs qui
ont des hauts et des bas et c'est
là-dessus qu'il va falloir essayer de
travailler pour les responsabiliser
c'est à l'image aussi de ce match il y a
une semaine à Vincen où vous menez plus
plôt facilement au bout de 20 minutes
presque de 13 points et puis derrière
bah il y a des cartons jaunes qui
s'accumulent et là ça devient très
compliqué et finalement vous perdez 16
15 ouais une grosse frustration à Vincen
la semaine la semaine dernière parce que
en en ayant réussi une première mi-temps
de de haut niveau avec le jeu qu'on
qu'on désire faire on est tombé après
dans la chamaillerie du coup moins de
concentration des cartons deux cartons
rouge ça fait jamais du bien et puis un
concours de circonstances faisant que
ils ont tout mis au pied dans les
dernières minutes et que nous on a raté
les balles de match au pied et puis une
défaite qui reste en travers de la gorge
et alors que cette équipe là sera je
l'espère et je le pense nettement
derrière nous dans le championnat
concernant vos recru là qui sont arrivés
à l'intersaison je sais que vous avez un
nouveau numéro 10 un nouveau demi
d'ouverture c'est le poste clé hein ça
fait partie de la colonne vertébrale au
rugby son intégration de son intégration
va dépendre beaucoup de choses derrière
he pour la la suite de la saison ouais
ça fait plusieurs saisons qu'on qu'on
cherchait un spécialiste sur ce poste là
il est arrivé c'est un ancien joueur du
club hein sa Hamza a joué déjà à plaisir
il il y avait 3 ans c'est un spécialiste
avec le jeu au pied qui va bien en plus
il a des qualités de jeu à la main qui
doivent lui permettre bah de nous amener
ce qui nous manquait jusque- là
c'est-à-dire une alternance entre bah le
jeu sur la largeur le jeu à la main et
puis aussi sur les temps faible être
capable de gagner du terrain au pied et
en plus c'est un excellent beur qui pour
l'instant qu'on utilise pas beaucoup
pour l'instant puisqu'on a aussi Benois
Baret à l'arrière qui qui est presque à
100 % mais ça sera un atout
obligatoirement dans la saison et qu'on
avait pas jusque là un petit plus oui
parce que là dimanche sur ce match face
face à mot le jeu au pied vous l'avez
pas utilisé dans vos temps faible en fin
de compte on n pas eu énormément de
temps faible si jeose dire on n pas
beaucoup passé de temps dans nos 22 m
Moot étant pas non plus en réussite mais
c'est vrai que on est un peu focalisé en
début de saison sur le jeu d'attaque le
jeu qui fait plaisir au spectateur fait
plaisir aux joueurs après quand on n'est
pas précis comme dimanche il aura
peut-être fallu aussi se retrancher avec
sur un jeu plus restrictif peut-être et
puis euh bah monter des balles en l'air
gagner du terrain tranquillement et on
serait peut-être pas exposé comme on l'a
fait dimanche très bien on suivra donc
la fin de la saison et puis la poursuite
he de de C de cette saison de Fédérale 3
en espérant voir les play-offs encore
une fois du côté de plaisir merci
Philippe d'être passé sur le 78 sportci
il est désormais le l'homme le plus
rapide d'Europe sur le kilomètre il y a
quelques semaines le viliséen Yann
dujarrier devenu champion d'Europe sur
PIST sur la distance il attend avec imp
patience he l'ouverture du vélo ome de
50 ans en Yveline en attendant il
s'entraîne comme il peut un mode système
D Jonathan villman était dans sa
roue depuis de saisons il vit une
seconde carrière exceptionnelle après
avoir arrêté le vélo pendant 8 ans Yan
Dujarier est devenu au pays de Gall
l'homme le plus rapide d'Europe sur le
kilomè pourtant le champion de France
court dans l'anonymat malgré une saison
2013 au plus que parfait le sentiment
d'avoir d'avoir réalisé l'objectif qui
était fixé dès le
départ alors un titre ça ne dépend
jamais de soi ça dépend un petit peu de
toutes les circonstances de course mais
il faut être près le jour J grosse
satisfaction personnel et et
encouragement pour la suite aussi parce
que ben ça donne envie de continuer à 37
ans le véisien rêve encore de décrocher
le titre mondial le seul qui manque à
son palmarès mais en attendant
l'ouverture du vélodrome de 50 ans en
Eveline se chef de cuisine en
reconversion s'entraîne en mode système
D au milieu des voitures il enchaîne les
kilomètres d'effort une fois par semaine
il doit même se rendre à chartre ou à
roubet pour caresser la piste j'habite à
20 minutes du Vélodrome euh ce sera un
pe de travail formidable maintenant on
attend de savoir quel créneau horaire
nous pourrons avoir parce que Ben les
créneaux sert réservés d'abord pour
l'équipe de France euh ce qui est sûr
c'est que je ferai partie des premiers
abonnés ça quel que soit le tarif il y a
pas de problème Kofi comme le surnomme
le pleoton n'est pas seulement bon sur
la piste il est passé sur H roues depuis
une dizaine d'années lorsqu'il arrête le
vélo la première fois et le roller lui
permet de progresser sur la scène j'ai
besoin du vélo pour progresser en roller
parce que j'ai des grosses lacunes
techniques donc le vélo m'aide à
progresser physiquement maintenant le
roller quand je travaille le sprint en
roller m'aide en explosivité pour le
vélo champion de France de sprint en
2012 Yann dujarriier s'alignera début
octobre sur les championnats nationaux
de marathon pour un nouveau titre juste
par
passion ce samedi 5 octobre vous allez
pouvoir aller faire de la zumba à
versaill dans le cadre de la zumba rose
une opération pour lutter contre le
cancer du sein Sylvie maréchal et Annie
bouquet m'ont rejoint sur ce plateau
toutes les deux vous faites partie de
l'organisation première question Sylvie
comment est né ce projet de de Zumba
rose
le projet de Zumba rose est né de
Eugénie Coro qui est donc la présidente
de Zumba rose avec Jud tocni qui est
donc
l'administrateur c'est une idée de ces
deux personnes de créer donc un
événement et plusieurs événements de
Zumba pour récolter des fonds et euh
pour pour la lutte contre le cancer d'
particulièrement le cancer du sein je
crois que la présidente de l'association
est bien concernée par euh par à l'âge
de 27 ans Eugénie a eu un cancer du sein
voilà et alors juste je sais que vous
êtes instructrice de de Zumba c'est
comme ça querctur de Zumba
rappelez-nous un petit peu le le concept
de la zumbaors la zumba ça veut dire en
propre mot bouger en s'amusant voilà
donc on on danse on introduit la danse
le cardio et en même temps des
mouvements fitness ce qui fait un bon un
bon exercice en même temps on peut aussi
s'amuser et pas seulement porter des
poids ni quoi que ce soit il y a pas de
poids enfin en tout cas pour la Zumba
Fitness uniquement c'est le sportif un
peu pour se se remettre en forme c'est
c'est une c'est une façon de de se
remettre en forme mais dans d' un côté
quand même ludique puisque la danse
vraiment fait fait partie c'est un un un
des
premiers une des premières choses à
laquelle on pense c'est danser ensuite
la vitesse donc le cardio et le la
tonicité tonicité au niveau au niveau du
bas du corps Annique bouquet vous faites
partie évidemment vous êtes conseillère
municipale à Versailles pourquoi l'idée
d'une Zumba rose sur Versailles il y a
un message spécifique à apporter sur sur
cette lutte contre le cancer du sein ah
oui il y a vraiment une idée à faire
passer la zumba parce que c'est un
phénomène à l'heure actuelle j'ai envie
de dire qui plaît énormément et c'est un
moyen de de de sensibiliser le maximum
de personnes c'est une journée qui sera
vraiment consacrée à cette
sensibilisation puisque le matin on aura
des conférences à l'UEA dont le docteur
meyur qui est président de la lit contre
le cancerivline animera il y aura deux
médecins le docteur G qui est oncologue
et le docteur combe qui est chirurgien
sénologue à l'hôpital minot plus une
esthéticienne qui est socio
esthéticienne qui sera présente pour
parler de ses soins auprès de ces
malades plus de témoignage très fort
puisque deux jeunes femmes une qui a eu
un cancer il y a 10 ans à l'âge de 38
ans et une autre qui a 38 ans maintenant
et qui vient d'avoir un cancer du sein
mais qui qui va nous permettre d'avoir
un regard aussi positif par rapport à ce
cancer voilà le but c'est vraiment de
sensibiliser les voilà les les femmes
par rapport à à ce problème du cancer du
sein oui à la fois de la prévention et
et avoir un autre regard sur ce cancer
du sein par rapport à la féminité de la
femme et puis la zumba est un moyen de
récolter de l'argent pour pour la LTE
contre le cancer et cet argent sera
consacré à l'aide aux malades plus
particul par que une une étude vient
d'être publié hein de la part de de
l'Institut National de la lutte contre
contre le cancer qui dit que pour
l'instant 53 % des femmes participent
aux dépistage et ce n'est plus en
progression c'est c'est alertant ce ce
genre de chiffre ça ça fait peur ou
effectivement je pense que la crainte la
crainte de la plupart des femmes c'est
d'aller donc se faire faire faire une
une mammographie ce qui est quand même
une une chose qui est pas très agréable
on le conçoit mais en même temps voilà
ça ça peut PE de l'acte médical mé oui
et puis de de l'annonce peut-être de
cette mauvaise nouvelle et c'est pour ça
que à luia on va les professeurs ont
décidé de vraiment sensibiliser les gens
sur l'importance et surtout de de de
dédramatiser euh l'ACT de la
mammographie et puis aussi s'il y a une
s'il y a une réponse à ça négative de de
pouvoir mieux gérer la la maladie
prendre les choses plus rapidement
surtout ou le plôt possible pour éviter
que la maladie effectivement de la place
je le rappelle donc c'est Samedi 5
octobre ce samedi toute la journée de
10h à midi pour les pour les conférences
et de de 14h à 18h pour faire un peu et
découvrir ou en tout cas pour les
aguéris découvrir et faire de la zumba
si si si on le souhaite il y a c'est
aussi un moyen ou pas de de trouver des
nouveaux élèves de Zumba où vraiment
l'objectif est clair et annoncé il y en
a qui viennent par curiosité ou juste
aussi pour pour donner un petit peu de
d'argent pour cette lutte contre le
cancer euh il y a des zumbaas on les
appelle les Zumba addict on appelle
vraiment les Zumba addict les gens qui V
qui viennent vraiment pour danser de la
zumba mais en même temps le le fait de
venir et de donner de l'argent qui va
servir notamment là pour le cancer du
sein c'est quelque chose d'encore plus
encourageant les gens vraiment se
déplace encore plus que si c'était pour
juste une simple zom à partie et là
c'est surtout que nous accueillons quand
même 15 instructeurs bénévoles et ça
c'est c'est dur à gérer un cours aussi
immense là parce que ça va être une
marée humaine de zumbaad comme vous
dites NON enfin on va dire que le le le
système est un peu réglé euh on fait pas
ça n'importe comment je je contacte les
instructeurs de Zomba qui veulent bien
participer ensuite je leur demande de
m'envoyer leur son et euh je fais selon
leur leurs besoins selon les horaires
euh et et je fais donc une une liste
avec tout est tout est vraiment préparé
comme il faut pour que la la journée se
passe s sans il y a un objectif de Don
anque booké sur une journée comme ça on
on espère toujours un chifre le plus
possible ou on n'ose pas donner un
chiffre on espère le plus possible voilà
donc rendez-vous ce samedi toute la
journée du côté de Versailles pour
découvrir en tout cas faire de la zumba
et et aider à la lutte contre le cancer
du sein oui merci beaucoup merci à vous
d'être passé sur sur le 78 sport à 37
ans sans sans transition à 37 ans
Laurent Le Pelletier est ce qu'on
appelle un speaker pour la 4e année il a
animé la grande classique
Paris-Versailles ce dimanche mais sa
voix n'est pas son seul outil de travail
rencontre avec un passionné de sport au
multiples casquettes images de Jonathan
villman après l'avoir couru participeré
au ravitaillement Laurent Lepelletier
est désormais la voix de la grande
classique à 37 ans Laurent est un jeune
speaker ce n'est qu'en 2009 lors d'un
cross qu'il monte sur le podium micro à
la main pour la première fois moins d'un
an après l'organisation du paris-vailles
lui propose d'animer la course
la première fois c'était beaucoup de
plaisir beaucoup de d'honneur et puis à
vrai dire je savais pas trop ce qui
allait se passer et ça s'est pas passé
comme je pensais la toute première fois
où la feuille de route elle était libre
j'avais carte blanche c'était à moi de
tout créer sur sur ce moment-là donc il
a fallu basculer un moment où on se
sent sous le regard des autres et puis
dominer dominer sa peur et puis prendre
le contrôle des autres par la voix et et
lancer tout ça très sollicité il crée
son auto-entreprise en mars 2011 mais
difficile d'imaginer que ce versaillet a
un autre métier au quotidien il est
gardien d'immeublees un gardien
passionné de sport qui met sa casquette
d'entraîneur d'athlétisme le soir après
le travail désormais chaque weekend il
anime des matchs de rugby ou des
compétitions d'athlétisme au micro il se
sent un peu comme un comédien qui
connais bien son texte je marche
beaucoup au feeling beaucoup à
l'intuition j'essaie de me faire
confiance pour essayer d'être dynamique
et elle donc non je pique pas trop des
choses aux gens par contre c'est vrai
que maintenant je commence à avoir mes
propres réflexes et je sais comment
poser les choses à quel moment dire si
ne pas dire ça avec des prédécesseurs
comme Daniel mjass sur le Tour de France
Laurent Le Pelletier voit plus loin que
les 16 km du paris-vailles et rêve de se
retrouver un jour au bord de la pelouse
du Parc des Princes le micro à la
main allez on passe au sprint au
résultats du
weekend
place tout d'abord au football une fois
n'est pas Coutu mais ce weekend les
championnats faisaient une pause pour
laisser place au 4e tour de la Coupe de
France seul Versailles était encore en
course et les joueurs de David jig ont
réalisé une belle contreperformance en
fait à puto s'inclinant 1 à0 le club de
puto qui évolue vous le voyez en
promotion d'honneur soit trois division
en dessous des Versaillais chez les
femmes les Amazones des lancour
découvrait ce weekend le championnat de
Promotion d'Honneur à tavni dans le
valdoise mais les joueuses de danilgle
se sont inclinés 3-1 et ont encore du
travail he il faut le dire pour se
mettre au niveau de cette nouvelle
division 3e journée de Division 2 vous
le voyez hein sur l'écran Montini se
déplaçait en Alsace àichet mais nouvelle
défaite pour les in montaines au
classement les joueus de Jordanie
grosses sont lanterne rouge de ce groupe
A avec trois petits points toujours sans
victoire cette saison et plus mauvaise
défense de leur poule avec 12 buts
encaissés la saison s'annonce très très
compliquée à Montini place au tennis ce
weekend l'Open de Guillan courour
rendait son verdict lors des finales qui
ont été faut le dire à sens unique chez
les hommes le Guillan courtois Guillaume
l ruste s'est incliné plutôt sèchement
hein face à Lilian breux 62 61 dans la
catégorie plus de 35 ans c'est stepphane
Ferucci qui s'impose sur le même rit
quasiment face à Julien Simon 63 61 et
chez les femmes c'est Fanie Andrian
jaffitrimau qui s'est imposé face à
Marie Fèvre 64 61 handbal 2e journée de
Nationale de H su évidemment les in
montaines euh qui recevait ici Paris au
complexe sportif Pierre de Coubertin
samedi soir sans Stéphane paysan leur
entraîneur malade les inimontaines entam
de la pire des façon la rencontre mené
très rapidement de H buts les
partenaires de Gabriel parloè ont pu
compter néanmoins sur leur deuxième
gardienne melodie jouant pour les
maintenir à flot sur les Jet 7 m mais
cela n'a pas suffi tout comme les SEP
réalisations de Fanny Jean-Baptiste
score final 2723 pour Ici Paris les
inimonages sont désormais 8e de leur
poule basket lors de la 2e journée de
National une he toujours chez les
féminines l'entente le chîn et
Versailles recevait samedi soir au
gymnase du bé Mondeville face à l'une
des équipes he il faut le dire les plus
faibles de cette poule les joueus de
Stéphane Roulet font vite la différence
grâce à une défense très agressive et de
beau stop sans être flamboyante au shoot
les ininoises sont beaucoup passés par
l'intérieur avec la grande Cécile d'cer
au terme des quatre cartant le résultat
est sans appel 64 43 avec cette victoire
les joueurs de l'ELCV sont désormais 8e
de leur poule basket toujours mais chez
les hommes en National 3 trappe se
déplacer à jeunevillier ce weekend lors
de la deème journée mais les traapistes
se sont inclinés de 10 points 75 à 65 et
sont désormais 7e de leur côté vous le
voyez les hommes de l'Entente le chaîn
et versaill enchaînne et se sont imposés
à domicile face à lzieux 71 à 65 et il
reste dans le bon vagon he de tête à
égalité de point avec le leader poissi
place au volleyball on reste dans dans
des sports de ballon pour cette 2ième
journée de régionalun on suit évidemment
Montini qui recevait anère à Pierre de
Coubertin après un premier set très
accroché perdu sur le fil 2826 les
imontins set petit à petit he sur les
attaques puissantes de la jeune ligne
d'attaque justement danière et encore
une fois coupable de quelques fautes
importantes au service les joueurs
d'Abdelatif nichli s'inclinent dans les
deux derniers sets 2516 et 2519 avec
deux défaites en autant de journée
Montini n'a pas encore lancé he sa
saison et reste dans le bas du tableau à
la 6e place dans les autres matchs de
cette journée de régional une le derby
entre conflan et plaisirville preux a vu
la victoire des plaisir plirrois 37 à 1
22 25 25 166 puis 2510 et 25 23 au
classement de cette poule de régional
une plaisir et second derrière
Sartrouville et Montini 6e on va
évidemment encore parler du Vélodrome le
dossier qui nous tient en haleine encore
quelques mois 4 mois exactement de
l'inauguration du vélodrome de 50 ans en
Yveline le calendrier des premières
compétitions se précise le nouveau cler
fontaine du cyclisme devraiit accueillir
les championnats de France de BMX début
juillet 2014 le tout premier weekend du
mois et le président de la Fédération
Française de Cyclisme monsieur
l'appartient a annoncé ce samedi que la
France allait se porter candidate pour
les championnats du monde 2017 avec ce
nouvel écrin canttinois un vélodrome
dont la piste vient tout juste d'être
terminée et qui verra la revanche
tenez-vous bien de la finale de vitesse
par équipe des derniers Jeux Olympiques
de Londres entre la France et la
Grande-Bretagne et pour terminer he ce 7
H8 sport comme d'habitude le l'agenda du
weekend prochain tout d'abord notez ce
ce petit cette petite date 19e édition
du parcourir Montini cette course de 10
km dont vous avez l'habitude dépar à 10h
dimanche au complexe sportif Pierre de
Coubertin à Montini évidemment en
football 3e journée de championnat de
Promotion d'Honneur gu encour reçoit
saint-jeun viève rendez-vous ce dimanche
à 15h30 au stade Maurice Baquet et puis
basket alors là il y a un derby que vous
pourrez suivre du côté du gymnase Paul
maillet à trappe entre l'entente le
chaîn et Versailles et trappe
rendez-vous ce samedi à 20h ce 7 sport
touche à sa fin merci de l'avoir suivi
encore une fois et n'hésitez pas à nous
donner un tous les résultats de vos
clubs via les réseaux sociaux et Twitter
à lundi prochain bonne
soirée